[موسيقى]
قرانا ان اهل الجاهليه كانوا يطلبون بثار
القتيل فيقتل احدهم اخا القاتل او اباه او
ذا رحم به فاذا لم يقدر على احد من عصبته
ولا ذوي الرحم به قتل رجلا من عشيرته
فانزل الله تعالى في الايه الكريمه ولا
تزروا وازره وزر اخرى صدق الله العظيم
ظهر الاسلام وانتشر في اسقاع الارض لكن
الجاهليه لم تطوى صفحتها وهي تتسرب تحت
شعارات طائفيه حينا
وعنصريه احيانا اخرى
والاولى بمن لسعه الظلم ان لا يكون من
الظالمين الى العناوين
الازهر يستنكر حرق كنائس وبيوت مسيحيين
بعد حرق نسخه من المصحف في باكستان
مقتل مغربي في اسطنبول وارتفاع منسوب
العنصريه التركيه ضد العرب
مذبحه كيماوي الغوطه هل تتزامن مع انتفاضه
درزيه وحراك علويه ضد النظام
بعد النجاح الساحق في الدول العربيه
كبتاجون سوريا قريبا في الاسواق الاوروبيه
هل تحول جو بايدن الى مندوب مبيعات اسلحه
لدى اسرائيل
مليون نازح من السودان حتى الان وقطار
التهجير على السكه
لماذا اعتبر وزير اقتصاد لبنان بانه يتسول
من الرئيس السيسي
[موسيقى]
مرحبا احتوت بعض افلام السينما على دورين
مختلفين لنفس الممثل وفي نفس الفيلم
وغالبا يمثل النجم شخصيتين متناقضتين تجسد
الصراع بين الخير والشر افلام ممتعه على
الشاشه لكنها مؤذيه ان تحولت الى واقع في
الحياه خصوصا اذا كانت الشخصيتان في انسان
واحد يتنقل بين الخير والشر
ذها وايابا والاخطر عندما يفعل الشر ويظن
انه خير
ان القران الكريم الذي يعتدى عليه من بعض
المتطرفين المجرمين في ظل تخادل بعض
الحكومات هو ذاته الذي يامر بالحفاظ على
دور العباده للمسلمين ولغير المسلمين وهو
الذي حرم التعدي عليها باي شكل من الاشكال
هذه الكلمات تضمنها بيان الازهر الشريف في
اطار استنكار مرجعيات ودول اسلاميه لما
تعرضت له كنائس ومنازل باكستانيين مسيحيين
من حرق وعدوان غداه هجوم شنه مسلمون ردا
على قيام شخصين مسيحيين بجريمه احراق نسخه
من المصحف الشريف اندلعت اعمال العنف في
منطقه جاران ولا في ضواحي مدينه فيصل اباد
بعد انتشار مقطع فيديو يعرض شخصين وهما
يدنسان المصحف اعملوا شغب الحقت اضرارا
جسيمه بالكنائس وايضا بمنازل المسيحيين
السلطات قالت انها اوقفت شخصا يشتبه
بتورطه في تدنيس المصحف كما اعلنت انها
اوقفت 100 شخص تورطوا في اعمال التخريب
والتدنيس والحرق خالف المعتدون الايه
القرانيه الكريمه ولا تزر وازره وزر اخرى
فكيف ينتصر المسلم للقران بمخالفته وما
ذنب هؤلاء المسيحيين الفقراء بطبيعه الحال
ليدفعوا ثمن جريمه مسيحيين وهم لم يرتكبوا
شيئا فيها خصوصا ان المسلمين يعانون من
تحميمهم اثمان افلام الارهاب سيئه الاخراج
حول العالم
علما ان مسيحيين وجدوا الامان خلال الهجوم
في بيوت جيرانهم المسلمين
بشهاده شبكه ايرون نيوز نفس المعيار كان
ينتقل من باكستان الى تركيا حيث خرب بعض
الاتراك محل المهاجرين السوريين واعتدوا
عليهم بالضرب ردا على اتهام شاب سوري
بالتحرش بطفل قاصر في ولايه اورفا قبل ان
تتدخل قوات الامن لتهدئه الاوضاع وفتح
التحقيقات مهما كانت الدوافع مختلفه لكن
فعل الانتقام الاعمى الذي لا يفرق بين
مرتكب وبريء هو واحد
[موسيقى]
هل نبالغ اذا قلنا ان البنده الاساسيه
لحملات المعارضه التركيه الانتخابيه
والسياسيه هو طرد المهجرين والمهاجرين
السوريين والعرب والافغان والافارقه طبعا
دون المساس بمشاعر المهاجرين الاوكرانيين
وغيرهم من الاوروبيين لقد فاز الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان في ايار الماضي بولايه رئاسيه
جديده لكن الحملات لم تهدا وواصلت
المعارضه شحن نفوس الاتراك في ضاائقتهم
الاقتصاديه ضد المهاجرين المسلمين يعني
عندكم مشكله مع اردوغان ما خص السوريين
فيها
تعددت الجرائم ضدهم واحدثها قتل مهاجر
مغربي على يد سائق اجره رفض توصيل الضحيه
طمعا ببعض الليرات الاضافيه افرج عن
السائق بكفاله في بدايه الامر ثم اعتقل
لاحقا بعد وفاه الضحيه في المستشفى ظهرت
مشاهد صورتها كاميره مراقبه تعرض المقيمه
المغربي محمد دومان لللكمات عده قبل
ارتصام راسه بالارض الامر الذي سبب له
نزيفا دماغيا ادى لوفاه خلال دقائق حيث
اكدت مصادر تركيا انها سبب الشجار هو رفض
سائق الاجره نقل دومان الى وجهته هل اصبحت
تحذير من سائقي التاكسي في اسطنبول او من
بعضهم نصيحه تلازم كل مسافر اليها
قبل نحو سبعه اشهر اوقع رجال الشرطه
التركيه احد السائقين النصابين بالفخ
فتقمصوا شخصيات سياح عرب وضبطوه بالجرم
المشهود حيث لم يوفر طريقه لسرقه الزبائن
الحداد
الشرطه التي صورت الحادثه بالكامل نصبت
للنصابه حاجزا خاصه في انتظار تشريفه
عندما مدخل المجمع التجاري فغرمته بمبلغ
كبير بسبب عدم تشغيله العداد وبسبب تصفحه
هاتفه الخلوي اثناء قياده السياره ثم
ياتيك نائب تركي معارض يصف التدفق السياح
والمقيمين العرب الى مدينته بالاحتلال فهل
يدرك هذا المتطرف حجم الخسائر الماليه
التي ستمنى بها تركيا لو قرر العرب تغيير
وجهات سياحتهم من تركيا الى غيرها علما ان
الدول العربيه من الخليج الى المغرب
العربي مرورا بدول الشام لا تقل جمالا
وتنوعا جغرافيا وثقافيا عن تركيا التي احب
ثقافه الانفتاح الجديده فيها فهل تنجح
المعارضه بتغيير هذه الثقافه
وبتطفيش السياح العرب في غفله من حكومه
انقره يرد موالون للحكومه التركيه بان
الحمله ليست على العرب بل على القيم
الاسلاميه التي يتشاركها العرب مع الاتراك
وينشرون في هذا الصدد سلسله فيديوهات
بينها سيده تركيه تنزعج من امراه محجبه
تركيه داخل حافله نقل فتقرر طردها من
تركيا باجملها وتقول لها اذهبي الى
السعوديه فهناك المحجبات وليس هنا وتصف
المصور بقليل الادب لانه صور رفعه اخلاقها
فرد عليها احد الركاب اذهب انت الى
اليونان اما هي فبقيه في بلدها تركيا
وهناك من يقول عندما الغت المجتمعات فرض
الستر تجرا المعارضون على فرض العري
فيديو
امراه متطرفه متخلفه اخرى تتهجب على سيده
تركيه محجبه وتصفها
فاي ارهاب يتوعد به هؤلاء للمسلمين ان
حكموا
جاكي
تركيا جمهوريه
وفي حافله اخرى تاديب جماعي لامراه متطرفه
قالت انها تقرف من خمار المراه التي
بجوارها فاجبرها ركاب الحافله على
الاعتذار لها وللجميع كي لا يطردوها
والشيء
في السويد التي تخالف قوانينها الكثير من
مسلمات الفطره البشريه
الاحراق مسموح لكن الاطفاء ممنوع اذا كان
الامر يتعلق بالمصحف الشريف بل ان امراه
حاولت اطفاء حريق جديد اضربه مونيكا بنسخه
من المصحف الشريف اعتقلتها الشرطه
السويديه المكلفه بحمايه من يهدمون الجسور
بين الشعوب وقمع دعاه السلام
[موسيقى]
في الاسبوع الماضي تحدثنا عن الذكرى
العاشره لمذبحه رابعه في مصر وفي الاسبوع
المقبل نتحدث عن مجزره تفجير مسجدي السلام
والتقوى في طرابلس بلبنان وهذا الاسبوع
تحل الذكرى العاشره لمجزره الكيماوي في
الغوطه الشرقيه بدمشق ولو اردنا احياء
ذكريات كل المجازر الحديثه في المنطقه
العربيه
لاحتجنا الى قناه تلفزيونيه لا شغل لها
الا باحصاء مئات الوف الضحايا وبالبحث عن
المقابر الجماعيه لشعوب دفنت على عجل عشر
سنوات مضت على الهجوم الكيميائيه الذي وقع
في الغدد الشرقيه في دمشق والذي راح ضحيته
اكثر من الف مدني غالبيتهم من النساء
والاطفال ورغم تاكيد التقارير الحقوقيه
والامنيه مسؤوليه الحكومه السوريه عن
الهجوم ورغم اعداد الضحايا الذين قتلوا
على مراه ومسمع العالم اكتفى المجتمع
الدولي بقرار مجلس الامن رقمي 2118 والذي
يقضي بانضمام سوريا لمعاهده حظر الاسلحه
الكيميائيه وسحب وتفكيك ترسانتها من
الاسلحه الكيميائيه
عصيان مدني واضراب عام ومظاهرات واحتجاجات
هذه السويداء صباح اليوم حشود لا تطالب
باصلاحات اقتصاديه او سياسيه محدوده بل
تريد اسقاط النظام هنا درعا وتحديدا
المسجد العمري الذي كان في 2011 ساحه
لتجمع الثائرين يرفرف اليوم عليه علم
الثوره السوريه مجددا والغضب ذاته وان كان
باصوات مختلفه يصدر من الساحل السوري ومن
معقل عائله الاسد
الرئيس الروحي للطائفه الدرزيه في سوريا
الشيخ حكمه الهجر منح غطاءه الديني
للمتظاهرين وقال لهم الله يحميكم يا شباب
وكل ساعه وفرج معه
نحن ما عم
نحكي
[موسيقى]
لهذا الشعب السوري كله اليوما ما كمان حكى
بلسان حالنا كمان ولهم كل التحيه منا
اينما كانوا الله حي الشيخ ييسر خطاكم وين
ما كنتوا ويحميكم يا شباب من الساحل
السوري ناشطون معارضون يقولون ان الرئيس
بشار الاسد لم يعد يتمتع بحاضنه شعبيه في
اشاره الى الاقليه العلويه التي ينتسبون
اليها لكن هل يستطيع فرد او اكثر ان يتحدث
باسم طائفه بكاملها يسالون فيجيبون اليوم
كل السوريين باتوا طائفه واحده هي طائفه
الفقراء
النظام كامل تبعه وهو عرب ما ضل عندك
حاضنه شعبيه اتسلحه وتقومها ليقتلوا لك
اللي قايمين ضدك مضل ضل عندك افرع امنيه
فقط بعد النجاح الكبير الذي حققته في
الدول العربيه قريبا افتتاح سوق جديد
للكبتاجون
اوروبا هكذا علق معارضون سوريون على تقرير
لشبكه بلومبرج الامريكيه عن قلق المسؤولين
في اوروبا من تدفق كوكايين الفقراء الى
بلادهم وكاله الامريكيه وفي تقرير لها
اكدت ان القاره العجوز تستعد لتدفق محتمل
لمخدر الكبتاجون لاسيما من سوريا ولبنان
عقب فشل المنتجين هناك في تسويقه لدول
الخليج العربي التي ركزت جهودها على
مكافحه تهريب هذه الحبوب في الاونه
الاخيره
هل اصبح المهجرون العرب بحاجه الى برلمان
المنفيين قصرا للتعبير عنهم مليون انسان
فروا من السودان في ظل وضع يخرج عن
السيطره
والمتقاتلون من دينا واحد ومن شعب واحد
الصراع في السودان دفع حوالي مليون شخص
الى الفرار للبلدان المجاوره فيما يعاني
اخرون ممن بقوا في البلاد من نفاذ الغذاء
وموت بعضهم بسبب غياب الرعايه الصحيه
اللازمه حسب منظمه الصحه العالميه
من المستشفيات الواقعه في المناطق
المتضرره خارج الخدمه منذ بدء النزاع
تحققت منظمه الصحه العالميه من 53 هجوما
على مراكز الرعايه الصحيه الامم المتحده
تتهم قوات الدعم السريع بالضلوع في
انتهاكات جنسيه ضد نساء السودان مع ان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع الجنرال الحمتي
يعبر دائما عن تقديره للمراه وعن تقديسه
للحياه الزوجيه
النساء والفتيات اوضح خبراء الامم المتحده
ان قوات الدعم السريعه احتجزت مئات النساء
في ظروف غير انسانيه ومهينه المراه لست
المجتمع
وانا لو سالوني بقول المراه 60% من
انا روح اذهبي فانت فرحانه
فانت ايه حره
كانت اسرائيل تجتهد لاخفاء صور جرائمها عن
العالم اما الان فبفضل مظلتها العربيه
التي باتت تتفوق على قوه مضلتها الحديديه
صارت لا تخجل من ترويع جيش احتلالها
للعائلات والاطفال الفلسطينيين في بيوتهم
غير الامنه فتنشر بنفسها فيديوهات للعمليه
العسكريه الاخيره
باقتحام مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله
تصدى الشاب الفلسطيني محمد ابو صبيح
لمستوطنين صادروا نسخه من المصحف الشريف
من سيارته واعتدوا على ارضه في منطقه
مسافر بني نعيم في الخليل والقريبه من
مستوطنه معالي جفير الاسرائيليه التي يغير
مسلحوها باستمرار على القريه الفلسطينيه
لسرقه محاصيلها الزراعيه واستفزاز اهل
البلد يعني محتل ارض وحرام كمان
مثل ارضنا في عندي قطعه الارض هاي اللي
احنا موجودين فيها
بدنا نعمرها ونعمل فيها معرش للدوالي احنا
معديين بالصدفه فشفنا سياره جوا الارض
جينا على المدخل
اجوا هم بدهم يطلعوا بدهم ينشردوه وقفنا
سكرنا عليهم الطريق يعني ما خليناهم يطلع
من مات دون ماله وعرضه فهو شهيد فانا
علشان كمشه تراب زي هاي ما حدا ياخدها من
ارضي بغض النظر بين مكان مين مكان ما بسمح
له ياخدها لو بموت علشانها هل تحول الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن الى مندوبي مبيعات لدى
اسرائيل فقد وافقت الولايات المتحده على
ابرام تل ابيب اكبر صفقه عسكريه في
تاريخها القصير مع المانيا هذه المره التي
ستشتري منظومه الدفاع الصاروخي ارو ثلاثه
ذات التصنيع المشترك بين امريكا واسرائيل
انها بمثابه صفقه عسكريه تاريخيه بقيمه
3.5 مليار دولار اسرائيل تبيع لالمانيا
منظومه ارو ثلاثه نظام دفاعي صاروخي طورته
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده سويا لاعتراض
واسقاط الصواريخيه فوق الغلاف الجوي للارض
بعد موافقه واشنطن وقعت تل ابيب على
الاتفاقيه الدفاعيه مع برلين في اكبر صفقه
عسكريه تبرمها الدوله العبريه في تاريخها
نتنياهو الالفيه الماضيه والمربوط دائما
بالماضي ذكر الالمان بجرائمهم النازيه بحق
اليهود قبل 75 عاما حاول النازيون في
المانيا الشعب اليهوديه الى رماد بعد 75
عاما تعطي الدوله اليهوديه المانيا ادوات
تدافع فيها عن نفسها يا لها من نقطه تحول
تاريخيه
وزير الاقتصاد اللبناني المحسوب على
الرئيس السابق ميشال عون يثير ازمه جديده
وهذه المره مع مصر بعد الكويت فيتهم بانه
يتسول من الرئيس السيسي قمحا على الهواء
ويفتح عينيه على اعداد الشعب المصري حماه
الله يوم دوله مثل مصر اللي بيستهلكو
لبنان بصيروا كلها بتستهلكو مصر وتلات
اسابيع يعني اذا اليوم انقطع لبنان وصل
لمرحله صعب بنقدر ناخذ كميه صغيره من
مخزون كتير كبير موجود بمصر طيب يا امين
كيف الرئيس السيسي بده يبعث لك قمح
وامبارح شايف صور الاف اللبنانيين عم
يتدفقوا على حفله عمرو دياب يلي كلفت مئات
الوف الدولارات للبنانيين
الواقع الاقتصادي المصري الراهن يصارع من
اجل تامين الامن الغذائي بحده الادنى
والرئيس السيسي يعد شعبه بخطه طموحه
لمواجهه الازمه الاقتصاديه التي لا يابه
بها او لم يسمع عنها ربما الوزير اللبناني
امين سلام بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان موضوع الازمه الاقتصاديه دي نوجد لها
حلول نهائيه ومش هطول عليكم فيها لكن عايز
اقول ان لازم خلال خطه طموحه جدا جدا
موضوع
الاقتصاد
والصناعه
ومستلزمات الانتاج وتقليل فاتوره
الاستيراد
ختاما تفرق سكان قريه بريطانيه في ارائهم
حول من يجب ان يتبوا رئاسه بلديتهم بعد
وفاه عمداتها حيث ان جميع المرشحين لا
يتمتعون بالقبول والشعبيه الكافيه لكن
رجلا من سكان القريه استطاع ان يوحدهم ليس
على انتخابه بل على انتخاب باتريك
وباتريك المقدام هو حصان قزم فاز برئاسه
البلديه بالتزكيه وبالاجماع
ليتطور طموح انصاره الان مع توجههم نحو
سابقه ترشيحه لرئاسه الحكومه وبكل فخر
مغرورون اهل القريه البريطانيه الجميله
اذا اعتقدوا انهم اول من ينتخبوا الدواب
لمواقع المسؤوليه الى اللقاء في عام 2019
مات رئيس بلديه القريه فجمع مالك باتريك
توقيعات كثيره بالموافقه على ادراج الحصان
القزم في قائمه المرشحين لمنصب العمده
سكان القريه كانوا غير راضين عن الساسه
فاجريت المنافسه بمرشح واحد وفازتريك ولكن
ماذا عن مستقبل الباترك السياسي من يدري
اعني انه منتخب من الشعب كرئيس بلديه
والناس يحبونه لذا ارى انه لن يضل طويلا
رئيس بلديه كوكنتون
[موسيقى]